"Утримання авто в європейських країнах
коштує в десятки разів дорожче, ніж в Україні",
написала у колонці на "Економічній правді"
голова Комітету Верховної Ради з питань
податкової та митної політики Ніна Южаніна.
DW перевірила:
На доказ своєї тези, Южаніна наводить
5 складових утримання автомобіля:
технічний огляд, страхування цивільної відповідальності
податок на власність, екологічний податок
дорожній податок
У випадку України виходить лише 26 євро на рік,
тобто 800 гривень за автоцивілку -
інші платежі не обов’язкові або в Україні поки не існують.
Для порівняння, утримання автомобіля в Німеччині
Южаніна оцінила у 531 (пятсот тридцять один) євро на рік
тобто 237 євро автоцивілки
плюс 254 – екологічного податку.
І якщо порівнювати лише ці показники,
то 531 євро
справді у 20 разів більше, ніж 26 євро.
Проте якщо звернутися до даних дослідження The Car Cost Index
міжнародної транспортної компанії LeasePlan,
яка щороку аналізує вартість володіння авто в Європі,
і на інформацію якої також посилається Ніна Южаніна,
то отримаємо зовсім інші цифри.
Так, щомісячна вартість володіння автомобілем в Німеччині
в середньому становить 618 євро.
ПересІчні німці від такої суми схопляться за серце,
проте йдеться не лише про безпосередні щомісячні витрати:
окрім пального, ремонтів, техогляду,
заміни шин, дорожнього податку,
податку на додану вартість, страховки,
відсотків за автокредитом, враховується ще й амортизація,
яка автоматично за 3-5 років
зменшує ціну нової машини на 30-50 відсотків
залежно від моделі й класу.
За цією ж системою розрахуємо,
у що обходиться автомобіль в Україні
на прикладі Volkswagen Polo
найпопулярнішої автівки в Німеччині у співвідношенні ціна-якість
за даними загальнонімецького клубу автомобілістів ADAC.
В салонах офіційних ділерів у Києві
ця модель коштує від 425-ти тисяч гривень,
тобто близько 14-ти тисяч євро.
Державна реєстрація обійдеться менше, ніж у тисячу гривень,
тобто до 30-ти євро.
Податок у Пенсійний фонд становитиме 4% від вартості машини -
17 000 гривень. Це близько 550-ти євро.
Автокредит залежить від багатьох чинників,
але в середньому відсотки без тіла кредиту
становитимуть 97 євро на місяць -
3 500 євро за ті ж три роки.
Страхування обійдеться у 2 300 євро -
обов'язкове для кредиту повне Каско
та "автоцивілка" протягом трьох років.
Бензин А-95 на місяць коштуватиме приблизно у 1 500 гривень,
за три роки, якщо ціни не зміняться
- 54 000 гривень або 1750 євро.
І останнє - автомобільні покришки хорошої якості -
приблизно по 100 євро за штуку.
Тобто ще 400. Амортизація – втрата у ціні
автівки за три роки складе щонайменше 100 000 гривень -
це 3 240 евро.
Витрати на техобслуговування, паркування та автомийку
не будемо враховувати.
В результаті виходить, що ціна володіння машиною за три роки -
11 770 євро,
на місяць - 326 євро.
Якщо застосувати систему розрахунків,
якою оперують фахівці таких компаній  як LeasePlan
або PricewaterhouseCoopers, то в Європі
утримання автомобіля не коштує в десятки разів більше, ніж в Україні,
а приблизно удвічі.
Утім, середня зарплата в Україні
у вісім разів менша порівняно з Німеччиною,
що вкупі з дорогими автокредитами погано позначається
на купівельній споможності українців.